et voilà c'était raza ma formidable
documentaire d'André vaitovic qui nous
fait l'honneur de participer à Z la zone
d'éducation aux documentaire bonjour
merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation à vos côtés nous avons le
plaisir d'accueillir également Jacques
maire bonjour vous êtes député la
République en marche des Hauts-de-Seine
membres de la commission des affaires
étrangères et vous avez présenté en
juillet dernier avec votre collègue
Frédéric petit une proposition de
résolution invitant l'Assemblée
nationale a condamné solennellement les
actes de torture et de répression
systématique du régime biélorus
d'Alexandre lucaschenko merci à tous les
deux d'être là et puis surtout voilà
deux invités parfaitement tidoine pour
répondre à toutes vos questions bonjour
les élèves merci merci d'avoir accepté
aussi de participer à cette émission
alors je vous présente vous êtes la
première HG GSP je me suis pas trompé du
lycée du lycée Molière à Paris alors
agsp pour histoire-géographie
géopolitique sciences politiques j'ai
bon super voilà avec votre professeur
d'histoire-géo vous avez énormément
travaillé sur ce film vous l'avez
décortiqué vous l'avez scruté et je sais
que vous avez plein de questions à poser
à nos invités mais tout d'abord juste
avant de commencer les échanges je
voudrais avoir votre sentiment sur ce
film qu'est-ce que vous en avez pensé
vous pouvez tout dire ce qui vous a plu
ce qui vous a dit si vous l'avez trouvé
trop court trop long dites-moi qui veut
commencer avant de voir le documentaire
je ne connaissais pas du tout le régime
politique de la Biélorussie et après
l'avoir vu ben j'ai pris conscience que
il y avait une véritable dictature en
Biélorussie sur les réseaux on a
l'habitude de parler de plein de choses
de connaître un peu enfin tout ce qui
est aux pression etc dans le monde et ça
enfin j'avais jamais vu et pourtant
j'estime que je suis assez connectée et
c'est sûr que c'était intéressant du
coup moi ça m'a choqué et bah comme ils
ont dit on en parle pas assez et de voir
ça bah ça traumatise parce que c'est des
jeunes ils sont pas plus âgés que nous
et ils vont dans la rue est manifeste
alors que en France on se plaint
beaucoup de ce qui se passe etc alors
que il y a pire ailleurs et on s'en rend
pas compte vous avez décidé d'appeler ce
documentaire un roman Belarus André déjà
est-ce qu'on peut revenir sur le mot
Belarus et le nom de ce pays finalement
et c'est vrai que moi j'utilise le nom
le Belarus parce que en fait après
l'indépendance de l'URSS le long a été
changé en fait moi j'évite d'utiliser ce
terme qui est soviétisé pour notamment
voilà montrer le côté d'un indépendant
de ce pays et d'ailleurs voilà le
Belarus c'est pas la Pyro aussi je pense
qu'un jour c'est tombé on va passer au
bon terme
est-ce que parmi vous quand vous avez vu
le documentaire vous êtes dit mais ça
pourrait être moi moi je me suis dit que
j'aurais pas eu le courage de résister
etc c'est pour ça c'est encore plus
enfin ils sont confrontés à quelque
chose d'aussi dur et d'autant plus jeune
et enfin si j'avais vécu ça j'étais pas
forcément la même personne je pense
j'aurais pas grandi pareil donc Vanessa
oui bah moi je pense que comme elle a
dit j'aurais pas osé sortir dans la rue
sachant que derrière il peut y avoir des
graves répercussions que ils sont
arrêtés ils sont tapés et ils peuvent
rien faire parce que
c'est les gens pouvoir on peut pas on
peut rien faire on est petit et voilà tu
voulais poursuivre
du documentaire razam
d'abord moi je l'ai vraiment bien
apprécié et je dis chapeau à André parce
qu'il montre quelque chose qui pour moi
est très important c'est qu'en fait il y
a pas de différence
dans la jeunesse entre un jeune français
un jeune biélorus un jeune Russe un
jeune allemand on est tous européen et
là c'est vraiment très très bien montré
vous dites je veux pas prendre de
risques j'aurais pas pris des risques à
sa place en fait partout il y a des gens
enfin ça ces conditions vous-même
peut-être dans ces mêmes conditions qui
ont envie de prendre les tendales la
liberté parce qu'il y a un tel écart
entre ce qu'ils vivent et ce qu'on veut
faire leur fait subir que ça devient
insupportable Aïssata écoute je voudrais
savoir quelle difficulté avez-vous
rencontré pendant le tournage est-ce que
vous avez eu peur ou pas
beaucoup de difficultés parce que moi
j'ai travaillé sans accréditation donc
déjà c'était un risque et puis on a vu
quelques jours après l'élection que les
journalistes devenaient des cibles des
autorités on a arrêté de porter les
gilets de presse on se cachait carrément
moi j'utilisais juste mon téléphone mon
iPhone pour pour faire des images parce
que c'était impossible de sortir avec
une caméra et du coup je voulais savoir
durant les manifestations avez-vous plus
peur d'être emprisonné torturé et voir
être soumis à la mort ou ça a créé une
union entre vous et qu'il y avait pas
avant les manifestations
moi j'avais peur d'être arrêté parce que
je savais qu'une fois arrêté j'ai
pourrai plus faire mon métier ça c'est
c'est tout c'est pour ça que je faisais
attention quand je sentais que peut-être
il faut partir plus tôt que prévu
aujourd'hui j'ai parté parce que moi je
mettais mes images dans un endroit
sécurisé protégé donc
non je vais pas vraiment peur d'être
enfin d'être arrêté torturé parce que
bon c'est c'est on a compris le risque
donc malgré tout il fallait quand même
travailler parce que sinon si on fait
pas le pouvoir
gagne André il prend des risques je
pense qu'il faut reconnaître ça et que
c'est vraiment je tiens mon chapeau
moi-même en tant que parlementaire
j'étais sanctionné par Poutine je suis
interdit d'accès en Russie parce que
j'ai fait un rapport en tant que
parlementaire français sur
l'empoisonnement de Navalny
donc on voit bien quand même que il
n'hésite pas si c'est nécessaire à
vouloir vous chercher à travers les
frontières et c'est justement plus on
est nombreux à s'y intéresser à
témoigner plus effectivement c'est connu
et plus on est protégé Elona tu voulais
poser une question en tendance ce
documentaire vous risquez de mettre en
danger votre famille et votre grand-mère
a dû quitter le Belarus car cela a été
trop risqué de rester
par votre vie
[Musique]
parce qu'en fait c'était pas si simple
dès que les parties elle a commencé à
recevoir des courriers des coups de fil
des autorités biélorusses qui la menacé
l'arceler demander son retour sinon les
mesures radicales seront prises etc
de cette privation de liberté
dans les collèges ou lycée
on nous commence déjà à formater le
cerveau c'est à dire que déjà dès qu'on
parle de l'histoire de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale il y a quand même beaucoup de
choses qui ont été réécrites puis des
comparent
on discute de l'actualité il y a que la
presse d'État qui est autorisé donc moi
je faisais constamment des préparer les
discours je cherchais toujours les
journaux de l'opposition enfin les
journaux indépendants et ça je naît tout
le monde ça gênait l'administration ça
je n'aimais profs parce que là c'est
vraiment organisé par l'État donc c'est
oui ça fait peur je voulais savoir si
vous avez eu des professeurs qui
glorifiaient le régime
heureusement c'était la minorité mais
quand même
donc on parlait de l'actualité c'était
toujours l'Occident ce sont des méchants
les robes vont nous faire général etc
etc donc là ça faisait quand même pas
très cool en plus pour nous qui sont
déjà bon on est quand même fait partie
de la même génération on est tous
connectés on est sur les réseaux sociaux
on a internet par rapport à mes parents
mes grands-parents qui ont vécu pendant
le SS donc non on peut accéder à
l'information à l'information différente
et on voit ce qui se passe dans le monde
on voit ce qui se passe en Europe donc
c'est très difficile de nous embrouiller
comme ça il est très important de garder
l'esprit critique
même ce que je vous dis il faut aussi il
faut pas croire à 100% il faut aller
chercher vérifier etc donc c'est comme
ça on apprend
on arrive à trouver la vérité je sais
pas si ça existe ça vous parle ça vous
rendez compte ce que c'est de d'avoir
même peur de d'aller à l'école et de de
s'exprimer ou de donner ses idées
parfois en répondant simplement à une
question à ces professeurs oui Vanessa
bah moi je trouve ça impressionnant
parce que nous on grandit avec le fait
d'être en confiance avec les professeurs
que si on a un problème ils sont là si
on sent pas bien ils sont là alors que
vous c'est tout le contraire faut se
méfier d'eux et bah moi je trouve ça
bizarre parce que on n'a pas grandi
comme ça et ça doit être super dur parce
que on peut compter sur personne
après il faut quand même dire que c'est
pas tous les profs heureusement qu'il y
avait des profs qui bien sûr avec les
portes fermées nous expliquer en fait la
vraie histoire et que le drapeau Belarus
enfin était différent après la chute
blanc exactement donc mais après c'est
vraiment c'est surtout l'administration
des établissements qui sont pas vraiment
des profs des formations même
aujourd'hui on voit que plupart des
ministres sont des militaires donc ce
qu'on peut imaginer un ministre de la
santé en France un appareil check
militaire c'est que même dingue donc
Aurélie quand est-ce que vous avez
décidé et quand est-ce que ça a commencé
prendre la décision de quitter le
Bélarus c'est quand même il y avait
plusieurs choses derrière
je me permets de revenir sur une phrase
qui est qui est que vous filmez en fait
il me semble que c'est Nastia dans la
salle de danse qui dit si tu pars c'est
une trahison c'est une solution de
facilité ça du ça a dû vous blesser
quelque
de classe qui m'ont un peu méprisé parce
que ils ont dit ah bah tu as la vie tu
as choisi la vie meilleure tu as choisi
la vie facile etc ce qui n'est pas du
tout vrai et donc moi je suis parti à 17
ans je voulais faire mes études de
journalisme amine ce que d'abord et puis
il y avait les élections de 2010 donc il
y a il y a 10 ans et j'ai vu la
répression moi-même avec mes propres
yeux aminsk et c'est en ce moment là je
me suis dit en fait je pourrais pas
faire ce métier tranquillement librement
ici et pour la possibilité de
d'avoir la liberté d'éducation je
choisis le schéma d'exil c'est pour ça
que je me qualifie pas comme réfugiés
parce que c'est moi que même qui est
choisi tu as une question pourquoi
avez-vous osé revenir en Belarus tourner
ce documentaire et pourquoi l'avoir fait
après la réélection de lucachenko pas
avant alors je le précise juste parce
que je trouve ça génial parce que vous
êtes en train de faire ils avaient tous
écrit leurs questions en mettant
Biélorussie ils sont tous en train de
refaire leurs questions en précisant
bien bellaris et je trouve je voulais
souligner cet effort parce qu'il le sait
pas forcément vous avez comme ça vos
questions c'est super sympa de votre
part c'est très chouette alors pour être
revenu à ce moment-là en fait je suis
j'ai suivi les élections à la campagne
présidentielle a commencé à bien avant
le jour J je voyais les gens se
rassemblaient je voyais les gens
s'activer sur les réseaux sociaux je
fais tout le monde regardait ce qui se
passait et tout le monde attendait cette
élection et je pense que aussi il y
avait que même une nouvelle génération
les jeunes de 20 ans de 25 ans qui n'ont
pas connu d'autres présidents et en fait
c'est un sentiment là que moi je suis à
Paris je regarde les images je vois
c'est manifestation j'ai dit il faut y
aller il faut y aller j'ai commencé à
proposer des sujets aux chaînes des
télés mais personne s'intéressait et je
suis parti parce que déjà c'est mon pays
je suis parti en tant que citoyen et
puis bah en fait sur place j'étais
journaliste parce que il y avait des
choses assez graves qui qui se sont
passés
la
dictée de
Mauges vous donnerai quelle
qualification
assez classique finalement c'est on fait
semblant de se légitimer par des
élections qu'on vide de leur substance
on essaye d'éviter les conflits ouverts
avec la population parce qu'on sait
qu'on est pas très aimé en revanche la
nature même profonde même si le visage
peut être un peu plus souple elle a pas
changé et quand on arrive effectivement
au moment où on se sent remis en cause à
ce moment-là on peut durcir et on va
jusqu'au bout
et vous le regardez un petit peu moi je
ferai un parallèle avec la Syrie
effectivement un régime qui est prêt
finalement à tuer pour pouvoir se
maintenir au pouvoir ça le définit quand
même au bout d'un moment c'est ce moment
de vérité qui le définit et aujourd'hui
ce régime est pas légitime et c'est une
décision collective de tous les
Européens de dire nous considérons que
ce régime n'a pas été élu en 2020 et
nous ne voulons pas avoir de rapport
avec lui et donc il y a jamais eu de
coup de téléphone par exemple entre
Lucas and Co et les chefs d'États
européens sauf une fois avec Madame
Merkel à cause du sujet immigration
c'est vraiment je dirais par rapport à
ce type de régime c'est vraiment très
important de bien clarifier ce qu'il est
et en fait c'est le seul pays
colorant noir un Europe sur le continent
qui utilise encore la peine de mort
c'est à dire que elle n'a pas juste n'a
pas été aboli mais elle est le régime
continue à l'appliquer vous parlez d'un
régime qui vécu au tout début enfin dans
le début du documentaire on voit cet
homme lors d'une des premières
manifestations avec un t-shirt blanc qui
est abattu cette image elle vous a vous
voyez à quelle image je fais référence
la répression est très violente
cette image du premier mort va frapper
les esprits
du documentaire qu'on a compris qu'il y
avait vraiment beaucoup de choses qui se
passaient et que c'était vraiment une
dictature où il y avait une oppression
réelle
dis-moi ce que tu as ressenti quand tu
as vu cette image
demander ses droits et il se retrouve
mort c'est peut-être un peu bête mais
c'est hyper symbolique enfin le fait que
il y ait un homme qui se fasse tuer
comme ça en plein milieu de la caméra
etc on dirait limite une scène de cinéma
oui tellement c'est genre aberrant qu'en
pleine rue ça dérange personne qu'un
homme parle proprement de son pays se
fasse comme ça fusillés aux yeux de tous
Vanessa tu voulais poursuivre
oui moi les gens ils ont décidé d'aller
manifester mais j'aimerais savoir
qu'est-ce qui a été le déclic qu'est-ce
qui a fait que ils sont dit non là stop
on doit aller
dehors et dire que on veut récupérer nos
droits
je pense que c'était quand même la crise
de la covid parce que vous voyez que
d'autres pays traités le problème mais
là-bas il y avait pas de mesures il y
avait rien c'est à dire que le cachetcco
donc le dictateur il sort des trucs mais
complètement dingue c'est à dire que il
faut aller dans les sauna il faut
pouvoir de la vodka donc et puis les
gens oui ça faisait rire mais après on
voyait les gens les proches les amis
tombaient malade de mourir et puis on
employé les chiffres officiels en fait
ça collait pas du tout je pense que
c'est ça c'était un déclic bien sûr
Elias tu veux une question cette
oppression Intel était présente depuis
le premier mandat de lucachenko assez
rapidement oui parce que dès qu'il
arrive au pouvoir par exemple il prend
en charge la télévision la radio donc il
monopolyse tout il y a plus de télé
indépendantes il y a plus de radio
indépendantes il reste quelques journaux
mais bon c'est pas que même les mêmes
les mêmes impact le même impact les
mêmes audiences et à la fin des années
90 on a déjà des hommes politiques des
opposants et des journalistes qui
commencent à disparaître et puis c'était
juste le début tu voulais poser une
question à Jacques maire du coup
monsieur le député quel est le lien du
régime de locatingo avec Moscou et
comment est-il défendu par Vladimir
Poutine
en fait la relation entre la Russie et
la Biélorussie c'est un peu c'est un peu
je t'aime moi non plus dire que
aujourd'hui il a bien réussi on voit
très bien
se réfugier derrière son grand frère et
si elle agit telle qu'elle agit
notamment par exemple en détournant un
avion où on utilise dans des immigrés
c'est parce qu'elles se sont protégées
par son grand frère même si elle a des
sanctions européennes
en même temps il a voulu montrer son
nationalisme et là André pourra
probablement en dire plus que moi mais
par exemple sur un sujet concret qui est
un sujet de liberté vous savez que la
Russie a envahi l'Ukraine
et bien et notamment la Crimée et bien
la Biélorussie le Belarus pour justement
montrer son indépendance par rapport à
Moscou et pour montrer à son peuple
qu'il protégerait son peuple de
l'impérialisme de Moscou n'a pas reconnu
l'annexion de l'Ukraine donc il y a
cette volonté de se dire j'existe
indépendamment de Moscou mais dès qu'il
y a un problème je me réfugie sous
l'autorité la protection de Moscou et
pour Moscou c'est un peu compliqué
est-ce que est-ce que le Belarus
aujourd'hui est un outil qui est utile
pour faire pression sur les européens ou
est-ce que ça rajoute quelque part des
conflits entre Moscou et l'Europe qu'on
a déjà beaucoup je pense que c'est cette
tactique je pense que à chaque fois il
se pose la question mais au bout du bout
s'il n'y avait pas Moscou je pense que
le Catch & Co ne résisterait pas Chloé
pourquoi avez-vous souhaité proposer à
l'Assemblée nationale cette résolution
contre le régime Bélarus que peut
apporter concrètement cette résolution
on a décidé de le faire d'abord pour
envoyer un signal au gouvernement pour
dire au gouvernement il faut y aller il
faut agir c'était aussi un message
vis-à-vis de l'opposition Belarus pour
lui montrer qu'on était avec elle parce
que il faut le savoir beaucoup beaucoup
de belarches nous ont beaucoup aidé
pendant toutes ces années sur le
dialogue et par exemple à Strasbourg on
a eu 16 personnalités Balarus qui depuis
des années travaillent avec nous pour
justement faire pression sur le régime
pour qu'il évolue parmi ces 16
personnalités beaucoup ont été
emprisonnés ou sont sur le point de
pouvoir l'être éventuellement et donc là
aussi il faut les protéger Killian on
t'écoute est-ce que vous avez reçu un
soutien particulier de la part de vos
collègues et députés est-ce que tout le
monde est d'accord pour condamner les
actes de location
on a eu un soutien très fort sur ce
sujet là on l'a eu à la fois à Paris on
l'a eu aussi à Strasbourg sur les deux
assemblées celle de l'Europe l'assemblée
française
c'est tellement évident voilà que ça ça
s'impose après il y a toujours
effectivement des gens qui pensent que
il faut pas se fâcher avec des gens qui
grognent parce que dans ces cas-là on
risque d'en venir aimer les affaires et
un sentiment un peu d'isolationnisme
finalement
mais ça n'a pas compté et je peux dire
vraiment que aujourd'hui si vous
interrogez les députés je n'en connais
pas un seul qui puisse ne pas partager
la résolution moi ce que j'aimerais
savoir c'est est-ce que si demain par
exemple Vladimir Poutine il retire son
soutien au Bélarus est-ce que surtout
est-ce qu'on peut arrêter la dictature
ou
ça restera toujours un homme puissant
le but de Lukachenko c'est de diffuser
les Européens
parce que depuis 18 mois depuis l'été
2020 on a pris des sanctions et des
sanctions très dures et lui au lieu de
négocier fait de plus en plus de
pression il a voulu diviser l'Europe ne
sait pas divisée l'Europe est restée
très unique y compris avec des pays
voisins avec lesquels on n'a pas
forcément toujours d'accord sur tout
comme la Pologne bon et je pense que
cette unité là elle va le faire
réfléchir parce que réellement
l'économie Belarus aujourd'hui est
vraiment en très grande difficulté et
donc s'il est à ce point violent c'est
parce qu'il y a une notion de survie
aussi et c'est évident que si le régime
survit c'est parce qu'il y a je dirais
le cordon
ombilical avec la Russie donc nous nous
pensons réellement que c'est pas du tout
dans l'intérêt des Russes
qui ont besoin comme nous de pouvoir
coexister ensemble sur un même continent
d'avoir un point de fixation de plus et
lucaschenko
pour la pour Poutine ça vaut pas
l'Europe faut pas sacrifier les
relations à l'Europe à l'occasion quand
lucaschenko menace par exemple que le
gaz qui passe par son territoire
soit plus vendue aux Européens tout de
suite Poutine dit
ça c'est mon gaz c'est mon argent tu
touches pas donc on voit bien que quand
même les intérêts voilà les intérêts
sont pas toujours convergents
comment s'organise la surveillance des
services de renseignement Belarus il y a
plusieurs méthodes mettre quelqu'un sur
les côtes
arrêter les arrestations arbitraires
mettre la pression ce qu'on a vu après
l'avion par exemple avec le jeune
journaliste arrêté donc il y a plusieurs
types mais en fait ce sont des anciennes
méthodes soviétiques qu'on lit des
livres sur l'URSS c'est exactement la
même chose et puis ce sont des tortures
bien sûr qui continuent à être exécutés
dans les
dans les prisons du KGB dans d'autres
prisons et voilà c'est la violence c'est
la peur
Dylan tu voulais poser une question
pourquoi ce sont essentiellement des
jeunes qui manifestent est-ce une force
d'opposition suffisante pour espérer un
changement de régime est-ce que les
manifestations sont présentes aussi dans
le reste du pays et pas seulement dans
la capitale
sont pas que des jeunes moi j'ai choisi
des jeunes parce que c'est ma génération
je voulais montrer ceux qui n'ont pas
connu d'autres d'autres régimes d'autres
présidents je fais exprès d'ajouter ma
grand-mère parce qu'il pouvait donner
quand même un avis extérieur avec de
quelqu'un qui a vécu une autre époque
soviétique et
aussi Notre Dame un des symboles de la
résistance et puis non ce que je disais
c'est que le mouvement n'a pas commencé
à Minsk mais ça a commencé vraiment dans
les petites villes et puis ça allait ça
ça m'empêche jusqu'à la capitale par
exemple juste après les élections on
avait plus de monde dans d'autres villes
du pays que dans la capitale
donc c'est vraiment tout le pays qui a
été mobilisé Nicolas
auront un effet suffisant est-ce que la
crise du covid s'aggravant ça va à
nouveau générer un deuxième mouvement où
est-ce que la terreur va s'imposer dans
le long terme
voilà moi je crois c'est un pari c'est
une vraie question nous pays Européens
on continue à mettre le maximum de
pression
qu'on ne lâche pas et je pense que avec
le temps ces régimes ne sont pas
éternels c'est génial c'est la France
s'intéresse à la cause du Belarus mais
en soi qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire parce
que à part du coup peut-être convaincre
la Russie d'abandonner
son soutien pour le la Biélorussie
qu'est-ce que la France peut faire
concrètement alors sur ce sujet
on est
France au sein de l'Europe premièrement
donc on n'agit pas seul on agit très peu
seul là on va parler de sanctions il y a
plusieurs dizaines d'entités juridiques
économiques entreprises et autres qui
sont sous sanctions l'idée est de faire
payer le régime et de faire je dirais
comment dire de faire en sorte de gêner
aussi bien les oligarques et le régime
que de soutenir la population on a
essayé de mettre en place aussi des
soutiens à la société civile mais le
cachenko a tout fermé donc c'est très
compliqué la sanction elle résout pas
tout la sanction elle a un autre
problème c'est que
par exemple on a fait des sanctions sur
les voyages aériens on a fait des
sanctions aussi sur les visas
[Musique]
début en véritable espoir des Bélarus
face aux scrutin d'août 2020 et surtout
est-ce que vous êtes la nature serait la
nouvelle présidente s'il n'y avait pas
eu de fraude électorale ouais je pense
je pense parce que c'était pas juste
la candidate
enfin le même je veux dire c'était
quelqu'un qui rassemblait tout le monde
parce que d'autres candidats potentiels
n'ont pas été enregistrés par la
commission électorale et du coup autour
d'elle on a vu entre d'autres parties
même si on n'a pas de partie mais
d'autres mouvements d'autres
personnalités qui représentée toute la
société les petites villes la capitale
les ouvriers etc donc c'était quand même
c'était une évidence c'était un sol
visage je pense que c'était l'erreur
stratégique du location de la laisser se
présenter
Alexandre pensez-vous que la population
est aujourd'hui résignée et accepte le
régime ou est-ce que les manifestations
ont suscité un élan des sports pour
faire tomber le régime
actuelle là aujourd'hui
l'espoir
reste dans la population mais c'est la
terreur la répression qui qui voilà qui
qui fait très peur les gens sont obligés
de contenu de leur vie en plus on sait
que les gens
ce que je dis tout à l'heure ne veulent
pas partir donc il y a plusieurs types
de de la mobilisation plusieurs méthodes
de se mobiliser de se rassembler il
distribue de des journaux ce qu'on ne
les appelle sa mezda c'est à dire que
les journaux avec des vrais informations
et le distribuent dans les boîtes aux
lettres donc il y a plusieurs types
d'actions et ça continue si on n'a pas
d'image de de manifestation dans les
rues ça veut pas dire que les gens ont
oublié ou enfin sont prêts à accepter
quelque chose que pensez-vous de ce qui
pourrait se passer si imaginons dans les
mois à venir lucachenko mourait comment
la situation au Bélarus et dans l'Europe
évoluerait
c'est une bonne question et beaucoup de
gens sur place le pose le questionnco
prévoit déjà il a déjà un scénario
établi au cas où il sera abattu ou il
décède il y a un conseil des sécurités
qui déjà formé ce sont des militaires le
clan proche du régime qui va prendre le
relais après je pense pas que les gens
accepteront facilement êtes-vous
favorable à l'accueil en France des
réfugiés politiques Bélarus qui luttent
pour la démocratie
alors on n'a pas être favorable ou pas
c'est un droit en fait
une convention qui s'appelle la
correction de Genève qui fait obligation
aux États qui l'ont signé d'accueillir
les réfugiés les réfugiés politiques et
donc on doit respecter ce droit
évidemment et je pense qu'en plus c'est
une obligation morale c'est-à-dire que
quand des gens on se battent pour les
mêmes valeurs que celles que vous
défendez voilà il faut être solidaire
donc il faut les accueillir ou pas
qu'est-ce que vous répondrez à Agnel oui
est-ce que est-ce que votre documentaire
il a il a circulé au Belarus est-ce que
est-ce que vous avez eu des retours
au-delà de des amis évidemment et des
gens qui font partie de ce documentaire
donc vous j'imagine que vous leur avez
envoyé les images etc mais ce que vous
savez si la circuler un petit peu s'il a
été vu si
même exprès de bloquer le pays pour la
diffusion c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
les pas accessible depuis le Belarus
pour que les autorités de la ruse
puissent pas accéder d'ailleurs on est
ouais donc il est pas disponible après
il y a quand même de moyens des vitesses
c'est à dire que avec les VPN on peut
quand même le voir et encore il y a
aussi l'ambassade Belarus qui à Paris
qui a sans doute vu le documentaire il a
pas très circulaire je suis plutôt
content parce que c'était pas le but
c'était de montrer ici
aux Français aux hommes et femmes
politiques français ce qui se passe
aussi à la population une petite
question quel est le message de votre
documentaire le message c'était déjà de
montrer
les gens comme comme vous vous avez dit
au début que vous
identifiez facilement
ça veut dire que ça a marché parce que
voilà même si c'est un peu loin on
connaissait pas peut-être ce pays à deux
ans et à 3 ans mais en fait ce sont des
gens comme nous qui veulent aussi vivre
libre qui veulent une vie meilleure et
voilà le message c'était ça le message
français
de l'âge de ceux qui sont en face de
nous aujourd'hui si
menait ce combat là qu'est-ce que vous
ressentiriez en tant que papa
je serai derrière eux sans hésitation je
pense que quand
si on est fait comme ça si on a dans ces
gènes la défense des valeurs et de la
liberté et qu'on les exprime on sera
juste le milliardième avant des millions
d'autres personnes qui ont fait
qu'aujourd'hui on est dans une
démocratie et je pense que on construit
pas forcément pour soi-même pour le
futur c'est vrai que c'est des paris qui
sont qui sont forts mais si les gens
c'était pas battus dans le passé
aujourd'hui on serait pas en France quoi
donc pour moi il y a pas le choix il
faut se battre je serai friable bien sûr
j'aurais peur bien sûr j'aurais peur
mais je serais très fier et je serai à
fond derrière Salomé pensez-vous pouvoir
revenir vivre un jour en Belarus
je voudrais beaucoup et j'ai croyais
sincèrement quand j'étais sur place
l'année dernière que en fait c'est juste
la question de quelques mois et puis je
reste je sais pas pour reformer la
chaîne de propagande à un chêne des
télés
indépendantes mais
tant que ça change pas je peux oui c'est
un projet on va s'arrêter là
malheureusement l'émission est déjà
terminée merci infiniment à tous les
deux André vaitovic Jacques merde avoir
participé à cette émission d'avoir
répondu à toutes ces questions merci et
bravo à vous les élèves vous pouvez vous
applaudir vraiment vous êtes très très
bonne question si peu de très haute
qualité merci beaucoup pour vos
réflexions merci à votre professeur
d'histoire-géo que je salue et qui nous
a permis de mettre en place ce
formidable programme et puis vous devant
votre écran et bien merci de nous avoir
suivi vous pouvez évidemment commenter
l'émission sur Twitter et sur la page
Instagram de la Chaîne Parlementaire Z
revient très vite avec une nouvelle
classe et un nouveau documentaire parce
qu'il n'y a pas d'âge pour questionner
le monde et ces images allez salut les
élèves merci encore
bien sûr
[Musique]